good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and
Sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science in the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues
the promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covet 19.
these include but are not limited to
delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus participation
participants excuse me for our selected
biomedical data science innovative Asian
lab program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project
development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington in June of 2023.
today I'm delighted to welcome our
speaker Madoff moraf from The
biocomplexity Institute at the
University of Virginia he is a 2023
bdsil mentor and he is a distinguished
professor in bioplexity and the director
of the division of network system
science and advanced Computing division
at The biocomplexity Institute here at
UVA and also a professor in the
department of computer science here at
UVA he earned his bachelor's degree from
the Indian Institute of Technology in
Madras he earned his PhD at the
University of Albany where he earned a
doctor of philosophy in computer science
and his research interests are in
network science sustainable habitats AI
foundations of computing and high
performance Computing over the last 20
years his division has supported several
federal and state authorities in their
efforts to respond to a number of
problems arising in the context of
National Security sustainability and
pandemic science including the coveted
teen pandemic and before joining UVA he
held positions at Virginia Tech and at
the Los Alamos National Laboratory he's
a fellow of the IEEE the ACM the s-i-a-m
and the aaas in continuing with our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme today's lecture is
entitled advancing the practice of
transdisciplinary Team science research
responding to the covid-19 pandemic
in his talk a Mata will be arguing that
pandemics are a complex system problem
that are intricately tied to the social
behavioral political and economic issues
that go beyond human health he will give
an overview of the state of the art in
real-time computational epidemiology
then used in covid-19 as an Exemplar he
will describe how scalable Computing Ai
and data science can play an important
role in advancing real-time epidemic
science as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
YouTube and so if you are joining us via
YouTube thank you so much also our
specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions via the chat feature in their
Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome Madoff we
are so excited to hear from you today
thank you so much Jack for such a kind
introduction and thanks to you and your
team members for inviting me to this uh
rather unique and amazing opportunity so
I hope I can do justice uh to you uh to
you in in terms of the program that
you're set up and I'm very excited about
the topic that I'm going to talk today
so I hope you can all see my slides uh
let me first thank my colleagues and my
team members before I get into the
details of the presentation as you can
imagine the the theme today is team
science and certainly is something that
we have practiced a whole lot uh the
work I'm going to present certainly is
done by a large group of folks in fact
I've I've already said many times in
other talks that my contribution to the
overall scientific part is becoming
smaller and smaller as the team becomes
larger and they become really good at
knowing these things I also want to
thank our funding agencies who have been
so kind in supporting us during the last
few years
by the way of references I've included
some here of course I'm available
to talk to any of you folks later on
um you know you can send an email to me
Jack and others have my email but these
references should help you uh you know
sort of get more details of the things
I'm going to talk about
so a brief background about ourselves
the the bio complexity Institute and my
division very broadly speaking the
division is focused on the problems of
massively interacting Network systems
and we intend to develop the foundations
and engineering principles that can help
us design such systems analyze such
systems optimize our systems and reason
about them
and I'm when I mean large I mean systems
between 10 to the 4 to 10 to the about
16 agents or entities they are not so
large that you can apply statistical
physics like principles and they're not
so small that you can really do it with
a paper and pencil like exercise and we
are focused in in our division on real
world societal networks uh not so much
the physical networks themselves
so what are the kinds of questions that
a group undertakes here are just two of
them
we have been very interested in coming
up with methods
um to understand how we could support
the development of sustainable and
adaptive social habitats and of course
today's theme and I'll go through this
in much more detail is how can we detect
respond and reduce the impact of the
next pandemic outbreak
so of course these problems are so large
that it's it's impossible for a single
person or even a single Professor with a
few students to tackle them so as a
result our group here has taken a
transdisciplinary team science approach
a TTS in short and focuses on building
you know novel tools and decision
support systems to to address these
complex systems problems and as Jack
mentioned you will see as I go along
that pandemics are a excellent example
example of this these kinds of problems
that require a transdisciplinary team
science approach
so just so that all of us are on the
same page uh what's transitionally team
science or TTS I've taken these
definitions from a series of papers I've
provided references to them uh in
particular Cara Hall star talk on this
was excellent uh there is also an
article in nature some time back
but TTS refers to a process in which
collection of individuals with expertise
in different fields work together over
extended periods by synthesizing and
extending discipline specific theories
and Concepts to create new approaches
and methods address a common problem
and this should be contrasted with other
terms which are seemingly close but not
same I found this particular graphic
rather telling I must say which tries to
articulate what team science and
transdisciplinary team science might
mean so they show an Apple for a
unidisciplinary team effort which is a
researcher from a single discipline
uh working you know perhaps with their
students or a few other professors maybe
in the same Department
a multi-disciplinary approach is one
where different disciplines work
sequentially each from their own
discipline
specific perspective with the goal of
eventually combining results to address
a common problem and a nice analogy in
this particular setting is a is a basket
of fruits so from a single fruit to a
basket of fruits then they go on to talk
about interdisciplinarity which is where
different disciplines work jointly to
address a common problem some
integration of perspective occurs but
contributions remain anchored in their
own discipline and I think fruit salad
is is their analogy for this which I
found quite telling again and finally
they make a a smoothie or a shake with
all these fruits merged together and
that's how they capture
transdisciplinary science and we have
defined this upfront in the previous
slide so I think from a single fruit to
a fruit shake is maybe a good way to
understand moving from a single
discipline to a transdisciplinary team
science approach
so our group has practiced this for a
long time now in fact I joined the core
group here when I joined Los Alamos as a
postdoctoral fellow back in 1994 and
I've then slowly become more more senior
person in the group and others have
joined in the meantime
but this group has sort of stayed
together the core team has stayed
together for a long time and I've tried
to uh sort of capture the basic elements
uh of our approach the first is to have
a common goal or a mission
second is to have a sustained and stable
funding from divorce agencies which
seems not so important but when you
think about it becomes very critical
because if you have a project that lasts
for a year two years usually you don't
have the time to do something that is so
Broad and in depth that you can build
such such an approach third is to
nurture a culture of diversity and
respect I think it's rather important to
do that diversity in all forms is is
important for a project like this to be
successful
we have found that it works best to grow
these teams bottom up now that is not
necessarily the case but in our
particular setting that turned out to be
the best way to do it we have most folks
joining us as post-doctoral fellows our
graduate students and then they grow
through the ranks and this has allowed
us to train them and essentially uh
engage them in a group in a deeper sense
and finally we work very closely with
policy makers and end users and
stakeholders
of course you know uh PTS
poses certain challenges and I wanted to
highlight a few of them here I'm sure
that you folks as you start working in
your Fields uh have experienced some of
these issues uh but and they're not only
specific to TTS but certainly they come
come out and and show up in a much much
more graphic way in a certain sense one
is conceptual and scientific challenge
which is that it's hard for
people to come together when they don't
have a Common Language it takes a long
time for people to be able to talk to
each other using a Common Language or
framework and and that's important
because once you do that you can really
start exchanging ideas in a more
meaningful way cultural variation among
team members this is you know variation
in terms of what how science and
engineering is practiced within their
disciplines so social science department
usually cares and and queries about
different questions and approaches then
a typical computer science department
for instance and those cultural
differences have important implications
again once the team gets built out this
these variations sort of mend together
management and Leadership challenges and
finally incentive recognition evaluation
you know a simple question that I can
pose for all of you is uh who gets the
credit for the work who is the lead
author these questions are important in
in a typical academic setting but we
have been able to overcome them and I
think it's doable in my opinion by
setting this team right and maybe that
is one of the things that we've done
somewhat well where we've been able to
keep this basic team together for such a
long time
so I'm going to for the rest of the talk
focus on a very particular complex
systems problem pandemics and hopefully
in during the course of explaining the
things we have done highlight the team
science and transistibility team science
questions that have come back Jack I'm
happy to take questions of course from
from the individuals uh if they if they
occur so let them you can go ahead and
ask them as they go along
so um there's a beautiful article by
Feinberg and Wilson after the during
actually the H1N1 pandemic they they
titled it is an editorial article in
science title epidemic science and real
time I encourage all of you take a look
at it beautifully written and they have
highlighted and and suggested five or
six different questions that we all
might want to study and turns out that
these questions actually are very very
relevant or were relevant during the
covet pandem 19 pandemic as well
so
our team has been building modeling
tools and decision support systems to
try and and help decision makers as they
responded to the covid-19 pandemic and
we wanted our models to go beyond simple
Notions of predictive uh use we intended
to build our models uh to First
synthesize available data to produce a
consistent and meaningful representation
to provide a range of interpretations
of incoming measurements
to evaluate a range of response actions
and behaviors to monitor effective
intervention strategies
to help coordinate understanding among
diverse stakeholders
and ensure that these models are used by
analysts and not just by Computing
experts
furthermore as the picture of the right
shows is a typical textbook view of
about a pandemic is and it evolves
there's a Time series of number of cases
potential number of deaths or
hospitalizations
during uh during a pandemic you start
fairly small and it grows has a peak and
then comes down and there are various
faces in this pandemic there's initial
phase which is the investigation
followed by recognition initiation
acceleration then it slows down in
preparation for the next round this is
actually a picture that we had in our
paper that we wrote in the early phase
of the pandemic but what is interesting
is
the real pandemic looks very very
different right so this is how covid-19
pandemic looks like
you have at least four if not five waves
just in the US so if you combine other
countries this story becomes even more
complicated
what is perhaps even more interesting is
that each wave
had different sort of features in terms
of its shape in terms of its peak uh who
got infected but also the underlying
cause of reasons in the first wave
largely we had lack of immunity mixing
in the population was fairly High during
the initial phase followed by extreme
restrictions in terms of lockdowns the
second wave people relax social
interventions followed by holidays
University openings
and behavioral adaptations the Third Way
which is a Delta wave which hit some
countries especially hard and even in
the US some parts of us harder
we had relaxed the social intervention
by then vaccines had come in so you saw
a very different spread and you can see
on the map the third map on the right
shows you the impact of the Delta wave
which was very very spatially diverse in
its form and finally June 22 where you
saw the Omicron wave which was very
large and I can continue on this thing
the waves have continued but this this
example for two years the first two
years of pandemic really captures how
different pandemics are from what a
typical textbook might think about and
it actually affects the kinds of tools
and models we might end up making
so
in our group we started working on this
problem in about
March of 2020 to some extent we were
lucky we have been working on developing
academic modeling tools from about 2001
or so so in some ways we were ready but
as you will see throughout the
presentation we had to constantly
reinvent what we were doing adapt
ourselves and really work to answer the
relevant questions that this particular
pandemic Post in some ways as my
colleague says oftentimes we found out
and most other groups found out that
their tools were good to solve
yesterday's problem so every problem
posed a new set of challenges and I'll
come to that
80 of us got together
and have been working on it consistently
over the last three years now believe it
or not and folks have very very
different background I've given a list
of department or you know
expertise that people have in in the
group we've also uh diversity in terms
of uh gender in terms of uh backgrounds
in terms of universities and
institutions and and so on so forth
the group has supported a number of
federal and state and local authorities
including HHS Department of Defense CDC
Department of Health here in Virginia
the Virginia hospital and Healthcare
Association the local universities NSF
and NIH and hopefully as I go along you
will you will see how the story unfolds
I've given a particular website here
that contains most of our presentations
and and papers we have written close to
85 papers in the last three years on
topic related to the covid-19 response
and we have also done more than 120
presentations to various agencies and
I'll talk about it more Brian Lewis has
been an excellent individual in terms of
doing these presentations week after
week to the state
so what sort of models do people use
then to study pandemics right there are
three class of models broadly speaking
of course this is a simplification but
hopefully capture the basic idea
the first class of models are what I
call data driven or statistical model
these models really don't try to
understand the underlying it's a causal
basis for why a pandemic might happen
they're just trying to understand this
from a correlational standpoint people
have used this quite effectively in
forecasting in terms of Niche modeling
where you just look at occurrences you
build a simple model train it using
either statistical methods or more
recent machine learning techniques and
then use to understand potential uh
occurrence or diseases across across a
region of Interest
there is another class of models called
the compartmental mass action models
this model set of models have been
extremely popular and the book by
Anderson May which is seminal book in
this area describes this model in great
detail
um and was developed in early 1900s and
has been the Mainstay of epidemiologists
mathematical epidemiologists who try and
study how epidemics might evolve in time
and the basic idea actually is
is motivated by models in physics in
chemistry in economics and they are
called compartmental mass action models
you divide the population of interest in
say three groups here you don't have to
have three the number of groups that you
use depend on the problem that you study
here the simple model is s i and r s
stands for susceptible I for infected
are for recovered and then you write a
set of differential equations which tell
you the rate of change of the
concentration of these these
compartments following pretty much a
print set of principles that you might
come across in chemistry when you do
chemistry or physics where you have a
rate of change of of the concentrations
think of this you know in the simplest
form of chemicals and molecules right
now
in some ways the Simplicity of these
models has been very valuable uh as you
can see the very very simple model to
State it's very transparent and as I
said has been the Mainstay of of com
mathematical epidemiologists for a long
time over 100 years and even during
covid-19 was effectively used because
you can quickly build it you can explain
it to folks and you can use it to make
certain decisions
there's another class of models that we
have been building called agent-based
models they're also called networked
epidemiology or network-based models
which use causal theories as well as
data to essentially build these models
out and they're a little different than
the previous model one of the perceived
weaknesses of ODS or compartmental
models is that there's a huge amount of
symmetry that is assumed in the models
right there are just three compartments
so every individual essentially who is
in state s looks identical but we know
that is not the case people have
different demographics different disease
States different levels of immunity
different levels of interconnectivity
between other individuals where they go
what they do what sort of Behavioral
responses they might have all these
things are different but sir models due
to the Simplicity are it's not easy to
capture these diverse diverse aspects a
network based model is much better
better you hear you have a node or a
agent per person in the population you
have an edge between two people if they
are in Social proximity of each other
and then you have a way to transmit the
disease from an individual who is
susceptible
is infected to an individual who is
susceptible so here for instance
initially in the node B naught might be
the infected individual and might pass
the disease on to one of its neighbors
V1 V2 and V or V3 and the disease might
continue I've given a pictorial
representation here this is picked up
from a paper that we wrote during the
Ebola crisis because we've also wanted
to highlight the nurses and and their
interaction with with you know
ecological uh elements that they are
part of
so what are the challenges that these
models might face I'll highlight these
challenges I bought six of them
but these challenges will also allow us
to appreciate the approach we have taken
and the role of Team science that comes
out very very clearly
so the first challenge is the Computing
and data challenge
as you all know very it's very hard to
get real world data to drive your models
it was especially so even during covet
19. now I must say that
during covid-19 the amount of data that
was made available was substantially
more than the previous epidemic
outbreaks and previous uh you know
infectious disease outbreak studies that
we had all done it's quite amazing how
the the community got together to do
this but even so data was relatively
sparse
and this affects the kinds of models you
can make furthermore the issue about
privacy uh digital contact tracing apps
became available but were not used as
much in the US although other countries
they were used much much more Computing
became a big issue getting access to
large Computing systems and storage
systems that can be used consistently
became harder and harder to get
foreign
is a modeling challenge here I want to
highlight that the models that one needs
to build
have multiple scales in them there is a
spatial uh scale in terms of the size of
space that you want to model the social
interaction scale which is from an
individual household
to a community to a county perhaps to a
state and to a country
and then you have a temporal scale you
know you want to understand the
progression of disease within an
individual
and then you also want to understand
the transmission between individuals
behavioral changes that have occurred
from hours to days to weeks and control
measures they take a long time to
Institute and then take time to pull off
pull back so you need uh multi-theory
multi-scale multi-level representation
of the system to be able to capture
these these uh scales effectively
third is a challenge that that arise
from understanding ecological and
biological aspects relate to viral
Evolution immune responses zoonosis and
vaccine development in testing
these questions become very Central you
all know that covid-19 there's a there
was a lot of debate of how the disease
essentially jumped into humans the
current belief is that it jumped into
humans in in China some people challenge
it I still think that's the right right
hypothesis but usually that sort of a
jump happens right now there is a
genuine concern uh you know not serious
concern but a concern about
H5 and you know in one style potential
pandemic you know we have seen this play
out in words and in minks in in Denmark
and other places
a third challenge
has to do with validation and
uncertainty quantification so in physics
It's relatively straightforward what one
means by validation they are well
understood theoretical principles and
people typically use predictive or
retrospective well you know validity to
either make sure that you can reproduce
a phenomena or you can predict a
phenomena now those are are good ways to
validate models here but they are not
the only ways in fact it's rather hard
to only use those as metrics for
validation structural validation model
turns out to be an important part of it
and this is an open area in many ways
it's something that we all are still
learning how we you know use data to try
and validate these models in the real
world
another challenge that is somewhat
unique perhaps for you folks is what
I'll call decision making challenge so
on the left I've shown your typical
what's called
UDA Loop uh basically where uh one
understands how models are basically
formed and decisions are taken at an
individual level but think about what
really happens in the real world every
person effectively is a decision maker
but they're decent makers of various
sorts uh I've just shown three kinds of
decision makers citizens themselves so a
person or a person who is the head of a
family might make decisions on behalf of
the family in terms of sending kids to
school deciding to go to work or not
wearing masks or not
we have decision making that happens at
the state and local Authority level and
then decided making that happens at the
level of say individual nurses doctors
Educators uh the point being each of
them needs to look at the system from
their lens and needs to contact specific
information to make that decision and
these decisions are localized and their
actions are also localized in in most
cases
the next challenge is communicating
scientific reserve and this turned out
to be very challenging as you all know
covid-19 caused a fair amount of social
and political debate in our in our
country and outside our country between
countries as well
so on one hand you want to talk and tell
people in the best possible way what
these results May meant but you need to
be thoughtful about it
and we'll again discuss it a little bit
in my talk
another challenge was of
coordination one needs to do
coordination at various levels of
echelon so to say at the level of say
managing the pandemic within the
University of Virginia that's what the
president's job would be for the
University but you have to manage this
pandemic and the level of a county at
the level of a state across various
states in the U.S across various
countries and within U.S across various
agencies you know between Department of
Defense who had a very different set of
consideration to CDC to NIH to FDA and
so on so forth
so that hopefully sets the stage for all
the challenges one faces in building out
models of this this guy now let me take
the next
um about 10 minutes or so to try and
tell you how we build out models in our
lab to support decision making and it's
a rather unique approach uh it's it's an
approach that is rooted in AI uh real
world data and high performance
Computing and theoretical computer
science
so the approach we take can be broken
down into roughly the following elements
about four of them in the first part we
take all the available data that we have
to try and build a digital twin
of a region of Interest so you might
will take information about the census
we'll take information about how people
might move using either trip Diaries or
information about their movement from
mobile phones to the extent that is
available in in a you know manner that
is anonymous we take information about
built infrastructure we take information
about the actions people take and
activities people take and fuse this
data using fairly interesting machine
learning techniques to build what I
would call a virtual social contact
Network so if I want to study
Charlottesville as my object of uh study
in terms of the epidemic then I would
build a virtual Charlottesville in this
you would have every individual resident
of Charlottesville represented the
family is represented houses and the
building locations represented and
people would go out doing their
normative activities during the day in
this virtual representation the key part
is is that the locations are real but
individuals are synthetic they are
virtual but they satisfy a rather
important property if you look at the
senses of our population
then it resembles the senses of
Charlottesville but if you look at a
particular address you might not find or
in fact you would almost never find
except for accidental reasons uh family
which is identical and we want to do it
because we want to preserve privacy and
anonymity of individuals and the goal is
after all to come with normative actions
not really specific
directives for a family or an individual
so that's how this is this kind of
network is made out this is a social
contact Network where as we discussed
individuals and nodes and edges
represent social contacts here I've
shown a bipartite graph representation
of it
we take then this information and make
what we call Live digital print
and the idea is what we have is the
representation of the system at the
start of the pandemic but that needs to
be continuously evolved updated using
ground data these details of the
evolving disease model case data
serology data interventions that are
going on uh information about policies
information about vaccine schedules
vaccine Supply information about uh you
know economic impact that's happening
closures that are happening all this
information is fed into the digital twin
to make it live effectively ready to use
simulations to project forward or do
case analysis
so once this Live digital twin is made
we used high performance Computing based
simulations agent-based simulations to
study how the disease would spread to
the pop you know through this social
contact Network what we did during the
course of this pandemic is uh and I
didn't say it here but essentially built
out the social contact Network for all
of us so there are 300 million nodes or
and about 10 to 12 billion edges in this
graph very very massive data structures
built out and so we needed high
performance Computing simulations to
really run uh you know disease
progressions through this virtual U.S
and as I said one single machine really
would not even do the job so we have
access A specialized and uh and a good
access to a big high performance
Computing cluster here at UVA but that
was not enough we had to actually use
two big supercomputers one in at
Pittsburgh called the bridges two and
another one at Anvil at Purdue spelling
is wrong I'll fix it but and well at
Purdue uh was also used to do this work
and the interesting part was that we
want to do this so that these machines
act seamlessly
to give you a sense of the amount of
data that is produced and used to run
these simulations
a typical case study would involve 2500
simulation instances
for calibration and about 10 000
simulation instances for projections
we are 3100 U.S counties 500 Days of the
simulation going forward
it reduced about 20 Gigabytes of
synthetic data to
start the simulation and would produce
about 1.5 billion entries or four
gigabytes of aggregate output data four
terabytes of individual level output
data so that you could then analyze the
output data to derive meaningful
insights and on the right I've shown a
typical workflow that the team underwent
week after week to try and run these
models where you start build out these
models updated at the start of the week
and then you turn back and come up with
reasonable predictions and assessments
at the end of one or two weeks depending
on the question
so
let me tell you how we used these
complex models that we built uh over a
period of time and I want to First
highlight that the work was done to
support
operational response
for State local and federal agencies in
real time during an evolving pandemic
and it's important to understand what
all these words might mean
from a real-time perspective our goal
was to try and build test and complete
the tasks that were driven by a strict
deadline it was not very useful to say
that we could not do it in the time that
the decision makers wanted the results
right you might as well not do it
there to be operational which means the
problems were derived from the current
needs and not made by us and the
resulting analysis should be useful to
the decision makers as well
results need not be perfect as a result
because the time was a constraint and
this is an art to figure out what is a
good balance between the scientific
rigor that you might be able to achieve
in the short time but still a meaningful
result that the policy makers might use
and the models can then be improved over
time as we go along and it last but very
importantly this was an evolving
pandemic which means that the questions
that we were posed but constantly
changing and as a result the data that
we had to ingest had to constantly be
updated the models had to be developed
essentially every time the new question
came out and software systems had to be
developed to try and capture these
models and finally wide range of
analytics and Document Preparation had
to be done to support this
just to give you a sense for how the
pandemic Evolution changed the questions
that we were posed by the policy makers
here is a a small subset of the kinds of
things we we really were engaged in back
in March 2020
um we were actually studying very simple
questions that related to importation of
disease to the U.S will U.S get get
infections in and once it was known what
were the first few hot spots
once we reached fall of March 2020 we
were asked to study questions related to
vaccine allocation
um we continued that problem to
understand fair and optimal allocation
we then moved the questions about
risks of new and emerging variants in
April 2021
it was clear from outbreaks in India
that Delta might cause a lot of trouble
in June we moved to impacts of and risks
of vaccine hesitancy in npis by that
time we had been able to successfully
vaccinate a lot of people but we found
that we're starting to slow down certain
people were very hesitant to take
vaccines
we then moved on to planning for
evolving strains which has become an
important and ongoing issue we move to
then understanding the impact of waning
immunity the first set of vaccine doses
that started to wane so people's
immunity had started to wane as a result
uh we then start to understand the
impact of vaccinating 5 to 11 year olds
if you remember September that was a
question in October the question moved
to understanding user boosters then we
moved to the Omicron wave in January
2022 actually about November 2022
afterwards we studied bivalent booster
uptake
moved on to impact of variant severity
and immune escape and we continue with
the same questions and try to understand
now intimacy of this potential disease
so you can see that
each time a very different set of
questions came out to try and help the
policy makers and this is just one part
of the story
um that we had to study so I have a more
sort of interesting thing for a single
problem like vaccine allocation that
goes to a similar part but I'll quickly
sort of go through it because of time
and just say that just the question of
allocating vaccines turns out to be a
rather uh complex problem and here I've
shown you how the problem changes from a
very simple theoretical question on the
left where it is stated as given a
budget of K vaccine you want to allocate
them most effectively all the way down
to vaccine nationalism coupling the
vaccine contagion with hesitancy
understanding the Notions of fairness
and Equity understanding the role of new
variants and understanding the roles of
noise and complete information in trying
to do this allocation
so a group actually over this three-year
period has built more than half a dozen
um
decision support apps dashboards that
were driven by the models we made here
are four examples that I have shown one
is
built on use of Mobility data this was
done with our colleagues at Stanford and
Cloud our state agencies to figure out
the impact of you know
essentially closing down certain kinds
of locations maybe maybe Gems or you
know stores or work locations or
religious practice you know locations
the second one which has been
operational from the very beginning and
is very similar to the JHU dashboard
that many of you might know at the New
York Times dashboard is about basically
doing assessment you know just capturing
the cases across the world and this has
been a very very useful tool we built it
very early on with them along the same
time that they did it
um and has been continued continually
used by a lot of people I think over a
million hits for this particular
dashboard we also built another
dashboard for our state and then scale
it up nationally to try and provide
individuals
unless and policy maker a sense of the
demand and the medical resources so you
know how many people uh are admitted to
the hospital what the occupancy might
look like over a period of time
um so that hospitals could be better
prepared in terms of uh you know the
utility that they can provide to the
response strategies and finally we have
a vaccine vaccination statistics
dashboard to understand how the
hesitancy was evolving over a period of
time uh in in our in our state
thank you
made a number of advances I'll probably
skip this but just to let you know that
we had to build out these tools almost
none of the results that I talked about
had ready-made tools that were existing
to solve the problems we had to really
work essentially to build out brand new
systems to try and address them
let me give you three examples and then
we'll go to the last part of the talk
and end we work very closely with our
department of health here and the
governor's office and other departments
Department of Education Department of
Homeland Security in our state
Brian Lewis has said that
multiple of you know briefings
essentially at least one briefing every
every week uh Andrew Warren did
additional briefings later on and others
did it as needed and we solved multiple
problems for the state as was requested
uh from questions related to vaccine
distribution allocation to contact
tracing to questions rate to
quarantining and testing uh one of the
big success stories for us was advising
our state not to build field hospitals
and as we understand this saved our
state you know anywhere between 40 and
100 million dollars because if you
recall in about May 2020 New York was
going through a terrible period in the
covid-19 pandemic and they had actually
built Javit Center as a field Hospital
they'd also gotten this Navy ship to
help them
uh and the question was whether we need
to do something similar to get prepared
in our state luckily our model suggested
that we might not see that bigger uh
outbreak here at that point of time and
as a result field hospitals will not
need furthermore we are also able to
tell them that to the extent we build
hospitals in the future we should build
them as smaller units that are mobile so
that you know they can move from one
place to another and not be placed in
one place and not be able to move
we've also supported the CDC scenario
modeling work for over now
two and a half years or so this is an
important uh Consortium uh Johns Hopkins
and NIH and CDC leads it but essentially
about nine or ten teams have come
together and
the teams with
working closely with CDC and other
federal and state officials come up with
scenarios so this is not about
forecasting but really trying to
understand what what would happen if
certain set of you know situations play
out and this was used for vaccine
allocations for kids it was used for the
very early mmwr report that was briefed
to the president it was also used by CD
senior cities officials and has been
used throughout these uh throughout the
pandemic you can go and take a look at
the website that is maintained and
captures we are on the 18th scenario
18th round roughly takes about a month
for one scenario to play out and then is
used by the officials as appropriate
we also support the scenario the
forecasting of the CDC and and UMass
Amherst and CMU ran
many more teams participate in this us
was one of the few teams that provided
Ensemble models uh and over the period
of this this pandemic and we're the few
teams that provided models at the
resolution of a single County so every
week we would forecast for the next four
weeks how the pandemic would look like
for each of three thousand counties in
the U.S a beautiful example of how you
make real-time models to try and drive
this these kind of systems and the
models did quite well we had a couple of
new ideas uh one was phase driven
Ensemble modeling one was using transfer
intro pistol methods to try and
understand correlations between various
signals
so this hopefully gives you a sense for
the diversity of you know problems the
diversity of teams that might have come
together a sense of real-time and
operational requirements that were posed
to make genuine real world impact on the
class problem that we were studying so I
want to end in next three minutes by
describing where we are heading one we
actually over act for a long period of
time now the group has built out as a
part of nih-funded proposal
a system called bvbrc it used to be
called Patrick before but the reason to
bring it up now is that's being
significantly extended
uh to try and make a resource center
where bioinformatic tools and genomic
information is being made available for
researchers across the country and in
fact across the world very widely used
resource which is now being extended
significantly uh 18 plus years of
continuous funding 600 000 page views a
month uh 9 million viral genomes stored
on this and during covid-19 this played
a very important role uh in terms of
people doing genomic analysis
we recently in October got a new Grant
as a part of the pathology genomic
centers of excellence there are five
such centers that were awarded across
the country we were one of them dcls in
the state leads it in addition uh to
dcls UVA uh your BCU and vdh are part of
the team at UVA our Institute as well as
the group led by Amy Mathers our
integral part of this this uh Center and
the goal is the realization Steps From
the realization that we really don't
have a seamless
setting right now in the country where
genomic information can be collected
essentially as the pandemic evolves and
that can be used to drive surveillance
and potential interventions so these
five centers are supposed to be able to
collect analyze
genomic data for you know ongoing sort
of diseases but also new outbreaks that
might occur uh you know for instance for
a while monkey pox was important
um you know there might be a new AMR
style outbreak in our hospitals here
Nitro or maybe there is another Outbreak
on h5n1 that might happen and the idea
is to be able to collect it and link all
these data sets across so that we can do
meaningful studies between uh between
various groups my sense is that this is
just the start of the CDC program we
expect many more states to participate
in this and really become much broader
National resource over a period of time
um
and the last part I want to bring up is
is a a Viewpoint that I have on where we
are likely to go with building out
models like this and
I think that
we need analytical tools and distance
support tools wherein individuals are
supported and not just typical
individuals in sense of a governor or a
president of a university right in my
opinion and the opinion of our group
every person is essentially a decent
maker and so the idea we have proposed
is a concept of P cubed Analytics where
the first P stands for pervasive
axis which is that every decent maker
should be able to make a decision at any
place any time and on using any device
this idea of Mark Wise and computer
science called pervasive computing
from where I derived this notion of
pervasive listen making
it should be personalized so the
information
and analytics that the president of a
university needs is different than a
head of the household and it's different
from a doctor who is working at UVA for
instance and is different from the
Secretary of health and so on so forth
and finally the decision maker should
have fairly precise information in
space-time and context so I think P
cubed analytics are going to be Central
to the story this
to sort of put this into play we are
currently supporting a rather
interesting challenge set up by the
White House it's called the pets price
challenge it's a joint challenge between
the US and UK the part of President
Biden's democracy initiative and the
idea is to build privacy preserving
tools
to enhance uh you know the you know use
of of data for social good and there are
two data sets that teams are using one
is from from banking industry to
understand fraud in in Banks into you
know inter-country fraud and the second
data set is provided by our group based
on the work I described before where we
have simulated the pandemic in Virginia
and in UK as a whole country and we have
individuals trying to build uh tools to
try and understand how data can be
shared and systems that can be built by
in a privacy preserving manner there's a
beautiful area in computer science
called Federated learning that is
developing which uses deep learning
along with idea of privacy preserving
learning to advance it so with that I
will stop Jack I hope this was useful
for you all thank you once more for
inviting me to this wonderful meeting
Mata thank you so much for sharing all
that with us
um it was really impressive to hear
about you know the the amount of kind of
computation and modeling and kind of
updating the models in your scenarios
and forecasting techniques
you mentioned that you had to leverage
several different high performance
Computing systems
um how did you manage to get them all
working together so flawlessly to be
able to do things like that you that you
described
yeah so uh I will admit that it was not
Flawless
Midnight Oil was burned but um we we
were lucky for one thing because we have
been developing HPC models and very
early on we saw that Rivera for all its
Trends is not going to be enough to do
these things so we approached NSF NSF is
a program called exceeds and there was
actually a Consortium of of companies
and institutions that came together doe
NSF Google Amazon that provided the
folks who wanted Computing Cycles but we
need a very specific class of cycles and
our colleagues at the Pittsburgh super
Computing Center were very kind to
support us so give you a sense for the
first six months the big machine at
Pittsburgh 30 000 core machine was
reserved for this competition every
night from eight o'clock in the night to
eight o'clock in the morning now after
about six months they could not afford
to do that it was you know others were
waiting to use a machine too even that
machine turned out to be not enough for
us and so we then requested more access
through the Purdue super Computing
Center the interesting part is that we
built out this what I would call a
spider-like system where we don't have
to access each of the machines
separately we essentially build a common
queuing system where you would set up
the jobs and the spider would
essentially figure out where we have
currently available cycles and use them
more effectively and that was part of
our garden Bell challenge you know where
we were finalists in in a competition
and showed that you can actually build a
cloud of supercomputers if you want to
call it that
that's that's cool and I'm sure that it
wasn't completely Flawless I'm sure
there was some some uh things you had to
contend with but it's exciting to see
that kind of thing come together the
notion of digital twins is still kind of
a relatively New Concept uh at least
only in the last few years have I heard
a lot about it so it might be just new
to me but it's interesting can you tell
us a little bit about what you know
about the history of that idea and the
creation of these kind of simulated
almost like a virtual in you know
version of say Charlottesville for
example or any other place what's the
history of that
um it's a really nice question Jack you
asked so the term digital twin was is
coined relatively recently but
and I think it doesn't do justice to
exactly what's happening there's a
earlier term that we had used called
synthetic information system that I
think also captures the basic idea very
similarly
and interestingly the basic idea of
synthetic systems was in my mind uh
studied in statistical science in back
in 50s and there's a paper by Ruben and
others that talk about it now
the current term digital twin really
came from engineering Sciences because
they were trying to study for instance
an airplane or a building uh and they
were trying to represent it digitally
with all the details when you took out
talk about social systems and systems at
the scale of a city
uh the kind of representation they're
talking about is not adequate in fact
you would I would argue that is no
single representation of the social
contact Network for Charlotte's Web so
you have to merge multiple data sets and
build a synthetic representation that
looks like Charlotte's work and that's
been our approach we started doing this
believe it or not back in 1994 there's a
very very important paper by my
colleague dick Beckman and his friends
at Los alvos that started building
synthetic populations uh back in 94. for
a project that was quite different was
an urban transport planning where we
wanted to understand how traffic jams
emerge and Chris Barrett who who is the
head of the Institute here was the pi of
that of that important project called
transims and he he really had this
Vision that we want if you want to
understand traffic you need to build
traffic bottom up if you want to call it
that and that requires us to build
digital representation of cities so it's
a relatively the old concept but the
availability of data and the ability of
tools has made this concept evolve
rather rapidly and actually the
acceptance of it has become much much
more clearer I did not discuss it here
Jack but an important use of this
potentially going forward is to train
deep learning models you know a lot of
people are developing tools for
autonomous cars and vehicles and
Microsoft is ingesting large amounts of
data to essentially train these
autonomous you know cars but they're
realizing that measuring data constantly
in the field is only one part of it so
they're starting to build simulations
that are realistic enough that can then
be used to train these autonomous cars
in the in the computer first
you know from a data science perspective
covid was sort of a data windfall in a
sense right as we had so you pointed
this out there was just so much data
coming and it was really unprecedented
and one of the things which I think
resulted from that is because there was
so much you know the fire hose of data
was just opened up that what the public
saw was really science being done in
real time
sometimes it was wrong or maybe it was
not as accurate as it could be and that
kind of put a little dent in the public
trust in some of the the forecasting
some of the modeling how bad the
pandemic was going to be where it was
going to be bad all those things I'm
curious if you have any thoughts from
your perspective on how we can better
ensure that we maintain public trust in
models like the ones you're describing
again a really important question
um I'm sure my answer is
um not going to be complete because this
is an evolving discussion
um
but I think first thing in uh in a
complex system like this
people have to be essentially educated
to learn that the notion of ground truth
is quite different if you want to take
analogy of of uh weather which is
something people use a lot
I think we can all agree that if we
predict a number let's say 70 in in
Charlottesville the temperatures it
tomorrow then either that number would
occur or not occur and we can measure it
with fair amount of precision
uh I don't think so such precise
measurements are straightforward at all
in a pandemic like setting when we want
to estimate cases
but I would like to highlight a few
other challenges just from a context of
forecasting in some ways Jack one is
and this this actually is rather
important and I would take it sort of in
in order if you want to understand
forecasting of physical systems like
planetary motions in general we
understand it very well the system is
deterministic at least for the time
scales we look at and as a result
you can see that you know we are able to
predict things really well you know
people have gotten used to it during
weather forecast people understand that
their uncertainty but largely it is fair
to say that our Behavior does not play a
role in how the weather evolves at least
in the short run climate of course
so much of the issue has to do with
measurements and to do with more and
more precise physical models
pandemics and other social systems like
economics and markets have this rather
important part where our behavior is an
endogenous aspect of the system
so if you do a forecast looking at the
forecast we might actually change our
Behavior
and that behavior in turn changes the
outcomes so just because a forecasting
tool predicted a certain number two
weeks from now and that number didn't
occur it is hard to
easy to discern whether that happened
because it could have happened and
people change their behavior or the
models were fundamentally just wrong
right so this co-evolution of individual
behavior and adaptation along with the
disease Dynamics I think makes this
problem rather non-trivial and
interesting so as a result a typical way
of evaluating is is hard and so this
this aspect has to be explained to
individuals better we as epidemiologists
and modelers have to do better as well
in terms of not not uh essentially
overselling our work yeah you know as
you you can imagine that happened to
some extent too uh everybody became
modeler a lot of people claimed their
models were doing very very well uh but
one has to be much more humble about it
and and point out the weaknesses that
these models might have
warm it up thank you so much for sharing
your work with us this is really
important I love the big dateness of it
the use of high performance Computing
and I I love the you know the the
caution that you provide us with to kind
of make sure that we're humble as we're
looking at these models and making sure
that we don't oversell them it's it's
super important but uh thank you so much
once again we really appreciate your
your presentation thanks to everybody
who joined us and uh everyone have a
have a wonderful weekend try to stay out
of the snow see ya next